welcome to this video playing the Jedi
Master yeah that was your doll right I
checked the side check this earlier and
whenever had an earlier game so let's do
something else here b3 based opening
okay so i can probably do some double
fianchetto business here ok so we
transpose into head shock style no
that's the line i have some experience
with and I think it's ok black is ok if
he plays it right but it's a bit ha ok
he really does not mind knight c6
surprising
okay it doesn't seem to lead to much so
let's go air for the typical way to play
this lets one set up here rookie 1 and G
for next t45 okay don't waste time here
this is really the total standard way to
play it maybe has some kind of d5
business but or b-five but my gvoice is
how it is normally played so I don't
want to question myself that too much so
f5 f5 is an interesting move there let's
do that with this kind of new file I
beat my first Grand Master this
particular opening and this idea it's
always a tricky business because you
give up a five but whites and taking
chances are pretty pretty substantial
given the pressure on jasek spawn and if
he takes it which he probably has to do
then 95 is coming in so that's why it's
concept here yes no Blackie black always
has come to play with this move but I
think let's see how to do this 95
maybe this is how more resilient than
you might think hmm what about rook f4
age 40 look deform look d4 edge for my
maybe I have to have to play I cannot
invest more time let's do that yeah I'm
really unsure as i said the f5 business
is always very very yeah it's very sharp
yum i'm giving away things but also get
taking chances in return so um 95 looks
very normal but yeah you can take on c4
let's see
95 bc form after that it's not clear
what my move is night age 6 is not going
anywhere
between age five and then look f3h three
this one maybe Wow
b.tech 0h 30 sorry
so I place that if i take it up in the
tkts Knight to f6 age seven is not going
to win and white has a winning attacker
there's absolutely no doubt about that
but now after age 6 i'm very sure but
how exactly do you win takes their 195
joke maybe just 95 to come i have six
if you attack with all pieces is usually
dangerous so he tries to ditch this porn
just for slowing down the whole thing I
don't have to take it he gives the
exchange now night d5 Roxy one so can
also go fo here before we're covering
from the side
I mean these pieces are very passive
they actually they don't do much whoa
it's no mate what am I thinking it's no
mate it just tell us h7 wow it's really
thinking it's over already ok
but it's probably still just a good
position how do I win exactly and my
king is also wide open this is a real
problem I'm morning my king is wide open
and I'm damn check okay that's the way I
don't have time here Bishop c5 maybe I
can take f6 now it takes Knight h6 is
going to win so he has to do that take
on f6 ok let's take care take ok and
just be quick here any direct win here
rook age 34 look there I don't know oh
he's 66 maybe nice chicken check me we
can check me that's the problem ok
GreenEDGE shriver still a big thread
I'm having those forever Cal check one
check here Benny fortune but here what
is the check now night f fraud check if
I go here I think you have to blame
check check check check check check now
check he has a droid best check check
draw chalford check check check drawn on
Vlad yeah this repetition I what a shame
man that was a complete win of course it
was so messy it was such a messy
position that has screwed it up so okay
let's have a look Yemen for look at 383
so this 95 winds yeah okay no you cannot
you cannot play this kind of position
perfectly in blitz and even with longer
time controls you probably will be
making many mistakes so the engine gives
95 winning which is no particular
surprise as I'm attacking with so many
so many pieces not quite sure what the
winning idea is in the first place
that's not idea check Wow go in here
it's made let's check mate yeah wow that
sets that hammer have a blue added that
kind of move I didn't didn't see that of
course okay I went here and oops sorry
that was the wrong wrong one age six it
seems the computer gives this is good
for black but you have to be really yeah
i mean the computer is of course
brilliant in this kind of position but
sometimes it's not the calculating deep
enough so I still have some vague hope
that this attack might be valid like
here h6 engine gives a wind from black I
thought maybe this is this is
interesting but Bishop takes is just
hauling yeah it looks dangerous but yeah
it's no made so probably could have done
that you played age six I went here here
Roxy three yet appear to give it all
back there then evil yeah the comp is
just all clothes one point something so
I'm like winning but no not it's not
easier I totally overlooked Knight f6 of
course I was just not seeing things
clearly here if texting sticks you have
to take it and e6 seems to seems to be
okay wow what a what a mess what a big
big mess and after that it is that is a
draw actually hear you that is a drama
queen age 57 in check check check check
is religious
the check check check check I have black
you're Jewish check one second on the
clock yeah fun game thanks for watching